-So, the film "Like a Boss" with
Selma Hayek and also Rose Byrne,
who is just a tremendous -
a wonderful person,
tremendous actor.
-And super talented.
-And you'd never
worked with her before.
Did you guys have fun?
-We had a blast.
Let me tell you something.
Now, this movie is about
friendship, right,
and with two women
that had been friends
since they were like
in middle school.
And I don't -- I don't kno
Rose Byrne for nothing.
They say, "Hey, we were thinking
about Rose Byrne.
What you think?" I said, "Well
I liked her in the 'X-Men'
and stuff like that
and in -- in 'Bridesmaids,
but I don't know how she would
get along with me.
You know, I don't know
if she gon' like me."
And they were like, "Well,
maybe you guys should meet."
So we met at my hotel
in the bar downstairs.
And we were supposed to only
meet for like 30 minutes.
But, see, then I had got
some of my medicinal --
[ Laughter ]
my medicinal vodka inside of me.
-Right, right. Your feet
were hurting again.
Incredible run of bad luck
with your feet.
-Right. I got this bunion.
It's crazy.
[ Laughter ]
But if you rub the bunion, goo
things happen for you in life.
-Oh, right. It's like a genie.
[ Laughing ]
Here, wait, let me get in there.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-David Letterman did it.
Um, anyways --
He did. David Letterman did.
-Yeah, I believe it.
Yeah, I could tell
when I did it, yeah.
-I'm serious.
-I believe you.
-David Letterman
rubbed my bunion.
-Did he really?
-Yeah, yeah, you should see it
It's great.
-Okay.
-Anyways -- It was nice.
So, anyways, we at the bar
and I'm telling her
about how David Letterman
rubbed my bunion.
[ Laughter ]
No, we at the bar,
and we're talking.
And she has some wine.
I have my vodka.
And she has another wine.
I have another vodka.
Next thing you know,
three hours done went by.
There's these guys at the ba
that I'm definitely
not their type.
They like, uh, you know, men
[ Laughter ]
And I start hitting on them.
And once I get
a little drink in me,
I want to, you know,
donate my womb.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter, applause ]
You're very giving.
-I'm very giving.
So I was like, "Hey,
you guys want to have a baby
If y'all want to have --"
And Rose is like,
"Don't say that to them."
I said, "No, they look lik
they love each other --
If y'all want have a baby,
let me know.
I'll pay child support.
Y'all can raise it.
I'll carry it, and I'll
breastfeed it for six months
and it's all yours."
And they was thinking abou
taking me up on that.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-But Rose thought that --
Rose was like,
"No, Tiffany, you can't do this.
You need to go to your room.
And then that's when I kne
we would be friends forever.
-Yeah, you'd be good friends
She had your back.
-Yeah, she protected my womb
-You have one more co-star o
note
that I want to mention is Bill
Porter.
-Yes.
-Talk about talent.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you took him --
So, you shot this in Atlanta
is that right?
-Yeah, we shot the movie
in Atlanta.
-And you took Billy
to a strip club.
-I took him to a male strip club
called Swinging Richards.
It's one of my favorite places
on earth.
-Bravo to whoever named
Swinging Richards.
I mean, bravo, yeah.
-They should give me some stak
in that company.
-Do they know you there?
-Yeah, they know --
Like, I go there --
Whenever I'm in Atlanta,
that's -- you can probably
catch me there.
-Okay.
-Guaranteed,
you'll see me there.
I mean, it's my favorite thing
in the world
is to see men dancing
with no shirt on.
-Yeah.
-Or pants.
And I walk in.
I walk in. When I walk in,
the manager sees me.
I think he pushes a button
or something under the desk,
because when I walk in,
soon as I --
I pay him my little money.
It's like $10, $20.
I pay him $20.
And then I walk in,
and then I get -- The deejay
goes, "Bam, bam, bam, bam!
Tiffany Haddish
in the building!"
[ Imitates air horn blaring
And then all the male dancer
come out,
and they running. "Hey!"
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Which one of y'all?
It's fun!
-You also had a fantastic,
last year, a Netflix special
"Black Mitzvah."
-Mm-hmm.
-You found out that your father,
You did a DNA test.
You found out
your father was Jewish.
-Well, my father told me.
didn't necessarily believe him
'cause you know men lie.
-Yeah.
-And then, I did my 23 and me,
and I found out that, yeah
he was telling the truth.
-And so you actually
had a bat mitzvah.
-Yeah, I had a bat mitzvah
I learned Hebrew.
I learned -- Vayetze is
what I did for my Torah portio
and I read it all out loud
in front of everybody.
And Billy Crystal,
he did my aliyah.
[ Laughter ]
And it was --
That's not funny.
That's beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-Congratulations on that.
And we've shown it before.
We've shown it before, but it is
one of my favorite pictures.
-It's my favorite picture
in the world.
This is when I knew we would
know each other forever.
-We would know each other
forever.
This is now 10-years-plus ago.
-Yes.
-This is 2009.
You auditioned for "SNL."
-Yes.
-And explain the photo
real quick.
-Yes. So, I have --
I always bring a disposabl
camera with me everywhere I go
in case I get in a situation
[ Laughter ]
And I was looking around.
I was like, "Is there any othe
black people here?"
And it was just
me and the janitor.
And then you had came out,
and I was like,
"Will you take
a picture with us?"
And you did.
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm so happy,
one, how young we look.
It's fantastic.
-Yeah, we look amazing.
Don't we look amazing?
-That's, I guess,
the real reason
I want to show it.
-Yeah, you look good.
-And two, what an incredible
decade you've had
since that photo was taken
It is always such a deligh
to have you here.
Thank you so much, Tiffany
-Thank you. Thank you.
I appreciate it.
-Tiffany Haddish, everybody.